good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday in the big news this week aside
of course from the unexpected
reappearance of my puff is that a gas
leak led to the explosion of three
buildings in Bozeman Montana oh my gosh
Hank when I heard about the explosion
the first thing I thought was oh I hope
Hank and Katherine are okay maybe
someone got so mad about the truth or
fail subscription box spamming problem
that it led to violence sorry about that
by the way we didn't think it would
happen and will never happen again this
in spite of three facts one Bozeman
Montana is 202 miles away from your
house in Missoula - at the time of the
explosion
you weren't in your house in Missoula
because you were in Florida and three
the explosion occurred at 8:19 in the
morning and Hank one thing that can
incontestably be said about you and 819
in the morning is that if there were an
explosion that did not involve your bed
you're fine
so even though you don't live in Bozeman
don't leave the house before 10 o'clock
in the morning and are currently
situated in Florida I read this news
article with great worry because I
associate Montana with you and Kathryn
people I like and don't want to get
blown up in a gas explosion meanwhile at
approximately the same time there's this
mutiny going on in the Army in
Bangladesh which would have been
hilarious sports and confidence had it
not killed so many people and also
endangered the fragile government now
Hank I'd like to say that I was really
worried about this mutiny and generally
with the political instability in
Bangladesh particularly given that
nerdfighters have raised thousands of
dollars which right now is being spent
to rebuild schools and build water
filtration systems in rural Bangladesh
but Hank to be perfectly honest I found
myself more worried about a gas
explosion in Bozeman Montana two hundred
miles away from your house then I was
about the fragile situation in
Bangladesh which makes me hate myself
what I'm arguing heck is that intimacy
leads to empathy clearly I've got some
work to do to get it into my caveman
brain that people I don't physically
know can still be really real and it
occurs to me that maybe one way to do
that is to use the people you already
know like me to connect you to people
that you don't know yet like people who
are poor in Bangladesh to that end Hank
I'd like to announce my half of the
ponen Google challenge Hank for every
ten dollars that we raise for the
uncultured project between now and March
22nd I will eat one peep on March 23rd
so for instance if we raise $1,000 I
will eat a hundred peeps on March 23rd
good
I actually gag from thinking about it
that's a lot of peeps and then I'll make
a video showing you what it's like when
someone needs 100 or 200 or God please
no more peeps and you will laugh because
that's the kind of person you are and
then a few months from now Sean will
make you a video showing the school that
you built the real school that will
educate real kids for a really long time
and then you'll cry that's right Hank
nerdfighting is a full service emotional
operation we take you to all the
possible feelings the link to donate is
in the sidebar along with more
information about what Sean does Hank
you'll see me on Tuesday as I try to set
the question Tuesday world record and I
better see you soon dressed up as Carrie
Bradshaw if you want to avoid a YouTube
mutiny I've been working a little bit on
my intro camera dance moves I now have
dance dance dance dance clothing move is
that better